alors maintenant on va passer à une
nouvelle idée à lui qui s'appelle
l'interview mans sont rouges soit la
bonne idée bonne idée alors
le principe voilà le principe c'est pas
obligé de répondre le contraire de la
question mais ont tous les cas on ne
répond pas la vérité à mentir il faut
mentir c'est l'interview tiberi on
aurait pu l'appeler par exemple un
d'accord je vois leur attention
l'eba xavière a beaucoup de charme vous
aviez a beaucoup de charme alors est ce
que laurent tu as déjà trompé sa femme
tous les jours tous les jours est-ce que
tu trouve ça trop cher les prostituées
écoute non parce que j'en ai
quelques-unes qui travaillent pour moi
et comme ça me rapporte non je trouve
ces joyaux trop cher tout a bien compris
que nous après on ne garde que bien
entendu pour l'épauler compiler tous à
bien entendre les bêtisiers qui font le
bonheur de la télévision comme on l'a
encore vu ce soir sur france 2 tu ferais
compte toujours les boîtes échangistes
toujours toujours c'est une passion chez
moi ouais j'ai commencé à sept ans et
demi ce qui est pas évident pour rentrer
de se déguiser je ne veux pas passer
pour un 1 de 43 ans beaucoup de
maquillage et puis tu fais l'un dans
l'autre on s'y fait comme on dit
c'est toujours ça toujours sur le sexe
c'est thierry sais quel âge tu t'es fait
c'était change pas qu'ils essaient de
faire croire qu'ils changent alors il
change de 74 cette question-là l'est pas
sur le segment des partis qui savait
sort qui t'as fait ça c'est quand même
je crois que leur faut passer à un autre
décorateur nouvelle émission laurent il
ya un bout de contreplaqué qui restent
vives en salle bien qu'on garde ordre
bien tu vends l'émission on avait
beaucoup de thunes c'est chiant de
contrôle qui tient par exemple une
question qui revient avec le sexe est ce
que tu utilises des capotes
tous les jours elle serait ce que pour
cuisiner je n'ai pas confiance ou dans
les aliments transgéniques la
charcuterie c'est ligne top100 souvent
donc tous les jours les jours alors
maintenant être encore plus obscène
linda on va parler encore plus
officielle
au bout de deux semaines
alors mettre encore plus obscène on va
parler de télévision
ton animateurs favori le lot
ben moi je suis un peu comme vous la
semaine dernière j'aime bien
comment s'appelle-t-il sabatier ouais et
puis j'avais une grande tendresse et une
grande admiration pour celui qui fait de
la radio maintenant qui faisait tout est
possible à comment il s'appelait su
quitter tout est possible bon annie
morandi j'aimais bien aussi
je veux un peu oublié les noms des gens
que j'aimais bien c'est lui qui truquent
de roswell à pradelles j'aime beaucoup
l'intégrité journalistique j'aime
beaucoup le le vrai contact et je n'aime
pas les le voyeurisme et les annexions
trash et je trouve que c'est des gens
qui ont apporté beaucoup à la télé c'est
bien c'est bien est ce que tu penses
qu'on pourra remplacer dorothée la
télévision l'an
non
ne serait ce que pour des millions
d'enfants il faut pas le faire j'adore
ça
remplace les pires en plein essor à lire
en temps je suis un petit peu d'accord
laurent est ce que tu as déjà couché
pour du boulot
c'était mon boulot que de coucher en
effet
lorsque vous avez longtemps dit qu'il
fallait à la télé fait les magouilles et
dans les couloirs mais alors attendez
d'un côté je suis raide partout j'ai
plus de boulot d'un côté si je dis la
vérité j'ai pu en retrouver oui j'ai
couché avec hervé bourges ça vous va
non mais ça on avait dû comme on parlait
pas voilà donc c'est quelque chose pas
diffusable est ce que tu gagnes bien ta
vie leur écoute
il ya des hauts il ya des bas mais je la
gagne pas assez à mon goût norway par
rapport à un ouvrier de chez renault je
trouve scandaleuses le blé qui peut
emmener chez lui par rapport à moi ouais
en faisant mécaniquement toujours le
même geste alors que moi que je fasse
preuve d' inventions de 2,2 je trouve qu
une échelle de valeur qui est pas bien
acceptés là est ce que tu penses être un
exemple pour résumer cela oui oui oui et
je comprends pas pourquoi on me casse
les couilles et des bustes de marianne
dans les mairies les écoles et là ils
attendent que je sois chauffe pour vous
tirer le portrait fait un but c'est quoi
le problème c'est qu'ils marchent bien
entre vous c'est qu'il vous fait
toujours il ya toujours derrière ma
laurent bary a peu de gens comme ça le
roomba toujours fait rire bien sûr
toujours cette fois les gens en deuil
d'un petit c'est pour ça que j'ai pour
ça qu'on vit ensemble ainsi du coup bah
oui le matin quand je me lève je viens
là la pêche et plaisir
laurent je m'en fous je dis ça
est-ce que tu trouve ça bien de mentir
je trouve ça affligeant comme une
interview est pourquoi les jaf est
convenu
ouais enfin je suis toujours le truc là
j'avais même dansé pour moi j'étais pris
à mon propre piège je me disais mais
pourquoi il ya moi j'adore cette idée là
très bien comment lolo
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux